127 voix voilà ce qu'il a manqué à
jacques françois quoiqu'il pour être élu
au premier tour lui le conseiller
d'opposition
ancien socialiste et qui a quitté en
marche il ya un an semblait promis à la
succession de raoul langlois
mais en trois mois la situation a bien
changé ces deux adversaires nettement
distancés ont eu le temps de s'entendre
plus de triangulaires mais un duel plus
incertain fabrice vaucher était est un
habitué de la fusion nous l'avons
conduit en 2014 on a vu ce que ça a pu
donner derrière bon après c'est plus un
homme de jaillir de fusion qu'un homme
de passion pour sa ville je ne suis pas
persuadé que l'ensemble des électeurs
qui ont voté pour la deuxième ou
troisième liste continue à avoir le même
vote puisque c'était de liste quand même
qu'ils n'étaient pas du tour et j'allais
dire qu'ils n'avaient pas du tout les
mêmes électeurs fabrice bosch est arrivé
deuxième a donc réussi à s'entendre avec
la conseillère régionale et l'air
nathalie roussel pour mener liste
commune
cette personne de ces dernières sur les
huit proposées ont rejoint la nouvelle
liste un rapprochement vu comme
inconcevable au soir du scrutin
mais le temps a fait son oeuvre
d'alliance et la fusion est arrivé assez
naturellement au sein des listes puisque
les deux projets qui était porté lors du
premier tour présenté un certain nombre
de points de convergence et les valeurs
également porté par les équipes étaient
relativement proche donc le tout
naturellement est tout simplement la
liste de second tour s'est constitué sur
la base d'un fort renouvellement dans
des équipes sur le papier leurs scores
additionnés leur donne plus de 200 voix
la balance mais un report n'est jamais
si simple sans compter le contexte
particulier et surtout l'abstention
record plus de 55% à leur dire que s'ils
veulent vraiment à voir
une dynamique pour pour la ville avoir
un changement un avenir beaucoup plus
serein pour coxon reviennent redevienne
la ville principale de lescott de rien
c'est d'aller les rencontrer on appelle
tous les gens qui sont abstenus au 1er
tour à venir nous soutenir lors de ce
second tour du 28 juin afin de renforcer
notre notre projet scrutin incertain
entre deux hommes qui avaient fusionné
ensemble il ya six ans
cette fois l'un des deux sera le nouveau
maire de la ville